hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you in another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful so in
this video we're going to talk about is
how to tell the difference between
direct variation equations okay and
inverse variation equations so what's
the difference well let's take a look
over here so on this side we're going to
talk about direct variation equations on
this side we're going to talk about the
inverse variation equations direct
variation equations are in the form y
equals K times X K is a constant some
books will say y equals a times X ok
where a is a constant inverse variation
equations are in the form y equals K
divided by X notice that X is in the
denominator Y or X is in the numerator
again K is just a constant when you go
to graph direct variation equations the
graph will go right through the origin
it's a straight line ok and it's going
to go up to the right with a positive
slope if K or the constant is positive
it's going to go down to the right with
a negative slope if K is negative now
let's look at the inverse variation 1 so
the inverse variation on ones they form
this hyperbola shape where it's
approaching the x-axis and it's
approaching the y-axis it gets closer
and closer but if K is positive you're
going to notice that the two branches
are in the first and third quadrants if
K is negative it's going to reflect over
the x-axis so that you're going to be
here in the second and fourth quadrants
ok so you can see that the graphs are
distinctly different right but now what
I want to show you I want to kind of
switch gears here a little bit if you
solve for K meaning you solve for the
constant by dividing both sides by ax
here you're going to see that K the
constant equals y divided by ax ok so if
you take the y-coordinate on the graph
right and divide it by the x-coordinate
you're always going to get that same
constant ok that's important we'll talk
about that in a minute but with inverse
variation equations you can see if we
solve for the constant by multiplying
both sides by ax to clear the
denominator here K is going to equal Y
times X or x times y meaning that if you
take the X&Y coordinates and you
multiply them together no matter which
coordinates say you use on that graph
you're always going to get that same
constant K so these are the
differences between direct and inverse
let's get into some examples so say they
give you this equation here 4x minus 2
equals y is that direct or is it inverse
well what I recommend you do is just try
to isolate the Y get the Y by itself so
y equals 4x minus 2 so what do you think
is a direct or inverse well if it wasn't
for this negative 2 if it was just y
equals 4x it would be direct you see how
it's in this form here and K would be 4
that's the constant of variation but
because the negative 2 is there and this
is actually going to be neither neither
direct or inverse okay let's go to
number 2 when you look at this one what
do you think director inverse well if
you solve for y by multiplying by 12
over 1 C those are gonna cancel you're
gonna get y equals 12x you can see it's
in the direct variation format the K the
constant is 12 the constant of variation
okay number 3 so we'll write direct here
for this one correct okay number 3 again
we want to try to solve for y so to get
the Y by itself let's divide both sides
by 4 ax okay
8 divided by 4 if we reduce that we get
2 divided by X so we have y equals 2
divided by X you can see that this is in
the inverse variation format just like
this one over here y equals K times X
and K the constant of variation is going
to be positive 2 so this one's inverse
I'll put I now another format that those
sometimes present this to you in is in a
table okay like we have here like an XY
table so they give us some coordinates
and they say okay is this representing
direct variation or is it inverse
variation well let's take a look so I'll
say this first one here so at first
glance it doesn't look like a whole lot
right but if we go back to what we were
talking about here about solving for the
constant of variation let's see if we
divide the y coordinate by the x
coordinate do we get the same value or
if we multiply the Y value in the x
value together do we get the same
constant let's double check so what I'm
going to do here let's multiply these
together so we multiply these together
we get 12 3 3 and 30 we're not going
the same constant that tells us it's not
inverse let's try dividing this time
negative 6 divided by negative 2 is 3
negative 3 divided by negative 1 is 3 3
divided by 1 is 3 and 30 divided by 10
is 3 so I just did Y divided by x equals
3 and so you can see that y equals 3x is
our direct variation equation so because
we divided the Y by X we got the same
constant that tells us that's direct and
our cast in a variation is 3 ok so here
with me so far we'll do two more
examples so this one let's say we divide
Y divided by X so 12 divided by 1 is 12
3 divided by 4 is 0.75 oh they're not
the same so we can see this one's not
going to be direct variation let's try
multiplying the X and y values together
1 times 12 is 12 4 times 3 is 12 12
times 1 is 12 okay looks like we're
getting 12 each time so this is inverse
variation y equals 12 divided by X okay
one more example but I just want to
point out something they get students a
little bit confused when you look at
this you say y equals K times X looks
like we're multiplying why are we
dividing here well again what we did is
we solve for K so when we get K by
itself Y divided by X equals K whereas
over here it looks like we're dividing
right the variables in the denominator
but what I did is I multiplied both
sides by ax to get the K by itself so
now you can see see that K equals y
times X so it's kind of like the
opposite like if you're solving and it
looks like you're dividing here you're
actually multiplying and if you're
multiplying you're actually dividing but
that's because we wanted to get the K by
itself the constant so what do you think
we should do on this last problem should
we divide or should we multiply what you
can check both let's do let's do
dividing so negative 32 divided by 8 is
negative 4 negative 16 divided by 4 is
negative 4 negative 8 divided by 2 is
negative 4 ok looks like we're getting
negative 4 each time when we divide so
that tells us that's direct variation so
it's y equals negative 4 times X now if
you want to check your work go ahead and
pick some points let's say we put one in
for ax
negative 4 times 1 yep negative 4 checks
out how about this one if you put 8 in
negative 4 times 8 negative 32 checks
out so you can do a quick spot check to
make sure you're on the right track I
hope you're enjoying these videos I hope
they're helping you in your math class
hope they're helping you to understand
better and get better grades subscribe
to the channel I look forward to seeing
you in some of the future videos and go
ahead and check out some of my past
videos I'll talk to you soon